Куточок Грузії в центрі Москви.
Це - ресторан і найбільша грузинська винотека в російській столиці.
Нині в колекції близько тисячі пляшок, розповідає шеф-сомельє Леван Хачидзе.
І на вино є попит.
- У нас усе-таки один кордон, ми дуже тісно дружимо,
і це вино супроводжує наших батьків, відповідно і нас маленьких, коли ми ростемо.
І люди дуже люблять грузинське вино
саме через внутрішньосусідські, людські відносини, які протікають за столами.
Грузинське вино повернулося на російський ринок кілька років тому,
але вже відвоювало свою нішу і,
за словами Левана, тепер гості запитують не тільки
про всім відомі Кіндзмараулі або Хванчкару.
- Я дуже здивувався, коли один із гостей запитав,
чи є в мене Чітісвале. Це перекладається як "риб'яче око".
Це сорт винограду, який мало хто із грузинів
нині пам'ятає і знає, а відвідувачу випала нагода
спробувати його на виноробні у Грузії.
Тобто влаштовують тури винними регіонами,
по виноробнях, і люди потім під враженням, мабуть,
гуглять, шукають і відвідують винні заклади в Москві,
в тому числі добираються до мене.
Сьогодні грузинських ресторанів у Москві - кілька десятків.
Сапераві або Піросмані - незмінний атрибут винної карти,
але на грузинське вино нещодавно зазіхнули
депутати російської Держдуми.
Образившись на нецензурний виступ
грузинського журналіста на телеканалі "Руставі-2",
почали обговорювати, як би грузинське вино,
а заодно і мінеральну воду, заборонити.
- Як можна було так реагувати на якусь нісенітницю?
На хуліганську витівку? Мало у вас своїх хуліганів?
Я не виправдовую грузинських політиків,
я від них давно нічого не чекаю. Але російські...
Я все-таки був значно вищої думки про російське МЗС, про Раду Федерації.
Про Держдуму в мене давно ніякої думки, крім матюків, немає.
Журналіст і телеведучий Отар Кушанашвілі дивується:
чому через протести молоді і слова,
нехай і непристойні, але однієї людини,
відносини двох країн знову почали разюче псуватися?
Після заборони прямого авіасполучення
між двома країнами з 7 липня Росія
мало не запровадила заборону грошових переказів.
- Я все-таки сподіваюся, що фраза Путіна,
що він проти санкцій, які будуть застосовані
до дружнього народу - мені ці слова, навіть якщо
вони офіціозні і сказані лицедієм,
а верховний політик - завжди лицедій,
вони гріють мені душу: а раптом до цього не дійде…
За період потепління в відносинах Росії та Грузії
спостерігалося зростання поїздок російських туристів у Тбілісі та грузинські регіони.
Актуальні політичні баталії для багатьох стали несподіванкою.
Хтось свідомо вирішив дистанціюватися
від політичних баталій, а хтось сподівається,
що все ще владнається.
- Я думаю, що це тимчасово. Зараз "покіпішують" і згодом перестануть.
- Це все політика, розумієте? Люди ні до чого.
- Суперечки, конфронтація і лайка ні до чого доброго не доведуть.
Після перших войовничих заяв у Москві
риторика стала спокійнішою. У Кремлі навіть
заговорили про відновлення прямих авіаперевезень, але лише згодом.
Тим часом деякі авіакомпанії повідомили
про збільшення рейсів Москва-Єреван і Єреван-Тбілісі.
Вірменія тимчасово взяла на себе роль
повітряного мосту між двома країнами.